what are the chances the intelligence
agencies are involved with the character
of jeffrey epstein in some way shape or
form with the character of epstein it's
100 percent guaranteed
that some intelligence organization was
involved but let's let's talk about why
let's talk about why okay
yeah there's multiple types of
intelligence assets
just like we were talking earlier
there's
foreign intelligence reporting assets
there's access agents
and then there's agents of influence
three different categories of of
intelligence right
one is a when you talk about foreign
intelligence reporters these are people
who have access to secrets and their job
is to give you their secrets in exchange
for gold or money or alcohol or
prostitution or whatever else right
their job is to give you secrets and
then you pay them for the secrets
access agents their job is to give you
physical access or digital access to
something of interest to you so maybe
they're the ones that open a door that
should have been locked and let you come
in and stick your thumb drive in the
computer yes or maybe they're the ones
that that share a phone number with
somebody and then you're they're just
like just don't tell them you got the
phone number for me their job is to give
you access
then you have these agents of influence
an agent of influence's job is to be
part of
your effort to influence the outcomes
in some way that benefits your
intelligence requirements right
of these three types of people
the least scrupulous
and the most shady
is your agent of influence because your
agent of influence understands exactly
what they're doing they know they're
working with one guy
and they know they're giving they're
using the influence to to manipulate
some other guy
when it comes to powerful people
especially wealthy powerful people
the only thing that interests them is
power
money is not a challenge anymore
prestige notoriety none of those things
are a challenge the rest of us we're
busy trying to make money we're busy
trying to build a reputation we're busy
trying to build a career keep a family
afloat
at the highest levels they're bored they
don't need any of that the only thing
that they care about is being able to
wield power
so
a character like jeffrey epstein is
exactly the kind of character that the
chinese would want the russians would
want
mossad would want the french would want
it's it's too easy because the man had
access to a wide range
of american influential people
for corporate espionage uses for for
economic espionage uses for national
security espionage uses it doesn't make
any sense
that a person like that wouldn't be
targeted it doesn't so the question is
who um
who
and whether
i think the
the the the really important distinction
here is was this person was jeffrey
epstein created
or once he's achieved and built his
network was he then infiltrated and
that's a really
sort of
important difference like at which stage
do you connect a person like that you
start to notice
maybe they're effective at building a
network and then you start making uh
building a relationship to where at some
point they're it's a job they're working
for you or do you literally create a
person like that yeah so intelligence
organizations have different strategies
here in the united states we never
create
we don't have a budget cycle that allows
us to create
i mean the the maximum budget cycle in
the united states is five years
so even if we were to try to invest in
some c operation or create some
character of influence essentially every
year you have to justify why you're
spending budget and that becomes very
difficult in a democracy like ours
however
russia and china are extremely adept at
seed operations long-term operations
they are willing to invest and develop
and and
create
an agent that serves their purposes
now
to create someone from scratch like
jeffrey epstein
the probabilities are extremely low they
would have had to start with like a
thousand different targets and try to
grow a thousand different if you will
influencers
and then hope that one of them hits kind
of like a venture capital firm right
invest in many hope that a few hits more
likely they
observed him
at some point in his own natural rise
they identified his personal
vulnerability very classic espionage
technique and then they stepped in
introduced themselves mid-career and
said hey we know you have this
thing that you like that isn't really
it's frowned upon by your own people but
we don't frown upon it and we can help
you both succeed
and
you know have an endless supply of
ladies along the way
you